he was obsessed with being the best ever  i was obsessed with being the most  dominant he was obsessed with being the  best ever  and sometimes you sacrificed a lot of  things and he did  all he did was work out  all he did is working he did was work  out and i knew all he did was work out  so i used to push his buttons all the  time because i knew  i knew what i was going to give you know  if i could have somebody else i can give  similar and more i was definitely going  to win so i was always the guy that  presses buttons the audience thought  that it was a personal thing we hated  each other but no it was me  and my leadership style and what i chose  to do to get him to perform at a higher  level how would you do that what was  your stop press his buttons how would  you press it tell us i pressed his  buttons and said this ain't your team  this is my team little man  you might be kobe but i'm the shaq